[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui une apparente tennis ici nous sommes
à lundi puis alors cette semaine je
pense que j'aurais pu faire quelque
chose de différent parce que parce qu'on
voit un peu partout commander fois les
situations se désagrège comment font
voile américains ont fait présentement
et ça peut amener maman des sentiments
d'inquiétude de de stress mais
simplement des fois il y avait pas de
nouvelles à travers la semaine et je
trouve que j'ai ici celles qui m'ont le
plus accroché et que je veux souligner
cette semaine dans le milieu des
communautés autochtones alors enfin
c'est quand même assez court parce que
je l'espère que vous allez explorer ces
bonnes nouvelles et commencer à les
faire a alors donné une place à l'ailé
ces peuples et vos médias sociaux la
bonne nouvelle que j'ai vu cette semaine
c'est que marveaux va pour le mois de
novembre que le mois de la culture
numérique n
ça fait très mal en français natifs
américains mais plutôt aux docteurs va
donner la place aux artistes et aux
personnages arterton dément avoir donc
leur faire une place d'honneur en hausse
mais aussi ce qui est très important
puisque quand on partage collectivement
une culture populaire telle quelle est
l'ampleur des films en vol ou même les
films de star wars ou les plusieurs
univers et quand je vois deux
fantastiques et bien voir une
représentation casey est adapté je
disais on s'entend que on s'attend pas à
ce que seigneur des anneaux et des
personnages autochtone mais quand pour
l'exemple de marveaux on peut voir une
présence des programmations gay je pense
que ça montre quand même une ouverture
puis un changement et on a pu le voir
avec par exemple exemple de blagues
pendant que d'avoir des univers rêver
d'astro futurisme comme mokanda de
donner envie de voir qu'est ce qui
pourrait créer six individus et des
communautés autochtones donc première
bonne nouvelle deuxième bonne nouvelle
pour moi c'est redford une militante de
standing au rac qui vont être libérés
après avoir été malheureusement
emprisonné pendant cinquante sept mois
pour avoir défendu son territoire pour
avoir défendu
la terre m'a malheureusement ça indique
encore aujourd'hui et 6 aux états unis
au canada il existe des justice à deux
vitesses selon les écrits mais selon
aussi les origines mais aujourd'hui
votre forme va sortir de prison et je
pense qu'elle va continuer son
militantisme des communautés sont prêtes
à les accueillir et à entendre son
témoignage donc très bonne nouvelle
team nous donne un peu d espoir pour
pouvoir voir les protecteurs de la terre
et de l'eau reprendre leur place
c'est-à-dire sur leur territoire dans
leur communauté et la troisième bonne
nouvelle et cela me plaît énormément
c'est les statistiques qui sont sortis
par rapport à la magie reour ouzou aux
effets du café ou plutôt aux effets de
la préparation envers les vagues de
kovic et les communautés autochtones en
réserve
c'est à dire de voir comment les
politiques très active des communautés
ont eu des résultats
présentement on voit qu'au canada dans
les communautés qui sont des réserves
il ya environ 482 code de conduite qui
ont été répertoriés malheureusement il
moins d'une dizaine de décès liés aux
corvées de 7 ans demain quand on compare
dans les pourcentages avec la population
canadienne
80% des quêtes qui ont été signalés sont
maintenant en rémission
ça fait vraiment beaucoup beaucoup moins
de victimes beaucoup beaucoup moins de
deux morts
et dieu merci grâce aux réactions des
communautés grâce à des politiques quand
même plus sévères et communautairement
très portés par les membres des
profanations donc l'engagement de la
communauté ont montré qu'on pouvait
aplanir la courbe et les communautés
autochtones le font présentement au
canada il aplanit cet accord est comme
ça on permet à un grand parti de pouvoir
protéger les personnes qui sont malades
et nos ennemis qui sont une ressource
n'est plus précieuses donc j'espère que
ces trois bonnes nouvelles pour moi vous
rejoignent
nous allons explorer justement les
milieux des bonnes nouvelles qui touche
ces communautés autochtones parce que
des belles choses les bonnes choses qui
se passent dans le monde des premières
nations et des communautés autochtones
partout au canada et amérique du nord
non juste une semaine
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo et
surtout n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
commentaires ou des questions on est
toujours ouvert à savoir un peu plus ce
qu'est ce que notre public veut entendre
bonne semaine